Tu es le chef des armées
mais ta popularité est au plus bas dans les sondages ?
Tu veux savoir si tu seras réélu
à la présidence de la République française ?
Ton prénom est François et
ton nom de famille est un pays qui commence par "Ho" et finit par "llande" ?
Envoie "MANDAT"
au 17 17 2017
suivi de ton programme
politique complet en fichier PDF
et tu sauras si oui ou non,
tu pourras de nouveau diriger l'État.
MANDAT
au 17 17 2017
Et si elle me mentait ?
Je ne sais pas si
je peux lui faire confiance...
Tu veux savoir si ta meuf est originaire du Poitou ?
Envoie Poitou :
P-O-I-T-OU
Suivi de son certificat de naissance
et d'une photocopie recto verso de son livret de famille
au 16 17 !
Poitou !
P-O-I-T-OU au 16 17 !
J'ai envie qu'on prenne un appart' à Niort.
Tu veux savoir si tu possèdes un cheveu sur la langue ?
Envoie MÈCHE au 70 13 13
Tu recevras peut-être un demi litre de salive
dédicacé par Akhenaton en personne !
Envoie MÈCHE au 70 13 13 !
Prix d'un appel surtaxé sous réserve de stocks disponibles.
Tu veux savoir si t'assures
en arithmétique ?
Et tu sauras enfin si tu touches
ta bille en calcul mental !
Envoie le résultat
de cette opération au 62 17 !
Hier, j'oubliais mon digicode...
et aujourd'hui, je zappe
l'anniversaire de ma meuf...
Galère, je dois avoir un problème au cerveau...
Tu veux savoir si ta mémoire te fait défaut ?